- Wow, that was so bad!
- I'm out of breath!
("The Star-Spangled Banner")
("Fergalicious")
♪ By the dawn's early light ♪
("The Star-Spangled Banner")
- This is embarrassing.
(laughs)
- Uh, ya damn right I've seen the video of
Fergie singin' the national anthem.
- I read about it on Twitter,
like, oh, you have to see this.
- I feel so bad for her.
I think she's singing
and she's like, whoa,
I think she just got carried away.
- But, you know, the
national anthem is arguably
the most publicly performed thing ever.
- Who rearranges the national anthem?
You just have to be so...Fergie.
- I think you can add
a little bit musically,
but what she did was almost just
like changing the emotion or the mood.
- She made a choice.
She made that choice and she
stuck with it the whole time.
- I just don't know if it
worked out this way, you know?
- Fergie is always going
to be Fergalicious,
and I believe that, but
the way that she sang it,
I think they called it jazzy.
- We never heard the first
person sing the national anthem,
so, sure, go ahead,
that doesn't bother me.
- You know, it's cool.
It's cool to mix it up.
(drumroll)
- No.
(laughs)
I'm scared now.
- Like Fergie sings it?
'Cause I can't.
I can't even come close.
She's like a diamond in the sky.
- Umm, that's a no.
- Not at all.
Not in the least.
Absolutely not.
- I mean, I will sing the
national anthem right now,
but I'm also scared.
- I'm down to sing the national anthem.
- Yeah, I'd be down to give it a try.
- I am so confident and ready
to sing the national anthem.
I'm literally the best singer ever.
- Yeah, I think I can sing it right now.
- Vocal warm-up, okay.
(sings vocal scale)
(hums)
- I can't do that!
("The Star-Spangled Banner")
- Where's my pitch pipe?
People?
Where's my pitch pipe?
(laughs)
- I'm so nervous.
It's totally fine.
I can start whenever?
- We'll just give it a go.
(laughs)
♪ Oh, say can you see ♪
♪ By the star's early light ♪
♪ What so proudly we hailed ♪
♪ At the twilight's last gleaming ♪
♪ Whose broad stripes and bright stars ♪
- Oh my God, I'm so nervous!
I was not nervous at all!
How do people do this in front
of a million people
broadcasting in their face?
♪ Through the perilous fight ♪
- Fight.
- Flight? Fight?
- It's fight.
♪ For the ramparts we watched ♪
♪ Were so gallantly streaming ♪
♪ And the rocket's red glare ♪
♪ The bombs bursting in air ♪
♪ Gave proof ♪
♪ Through the night ♪
♪ That our flag ♪
♪ Was still there ♪
♪ Oh, say does that ♪
♪ Star-Spangled ♪
♪ Banner ♪
♪ Yet wave ♪
♪ O'er the land ♪
♪ Of the free ♪
♪ And the home ♪
♪ Of the ♪
♪ Brave ♪
(applause)
- I definitely messed up the words.
- You know what, it's harder
than it looks, people.
- I literally could feel
my nerves and my voice.
- And so I cannot begin
to imagine what it's like
for the icons of the world to do this
in front of billions of people.
- It's cool to take artistic liberty,
but just maybe run that by someone and see
if it's tasteful before you go for it.
(soft guitar music)
(hinge creaks)